[Musica]
favara parigi sola andata
favara parigina c'e ritorno vuoi dire mi
viola sempre a puntualizzare no carla
siti che ripete sempre la stessa frase
cesaro po tutti se non va viola smettila
d'accordo anche se quando dice queste
cose ti farei
non so che ci farei carla sveglia
diametro messo una bella storia d'amore
fantasia
hai ragione ma in parte la storia l'ha
conosciuta
anzi la vivi tu ed io mamma e papà i
sette cortili favara parigi confuse in
aria come sempre ma no tu se a favara
lo sai perché ci a trovare o in parte
conosce andrea bartoli florinda sajeva i
teatri ea venitemi a prendere a mia
sorella ma certo che li conosco sono
come papà conosci l'inizio della loro
storia d'amore in parte sai cosa hanno
fatto a favara forse viola guarda che te
le donne da esperto stricnina sì so
qualcosa sun e voi lo sapete
mamma mamma racconta tutti com'è andata
questa storia
[Musica]
[Applauso]
probabilmente loro vi hanno incuriositi
io vi racconterò la storia di favara e
di farm ma vi racconterò soprattutto
quella che è la mia storia la mia storia
d'amore quella tra me e andrea sin da
subito noi abbiamo capito che il
matrimonio non sarebbe mai stato un
punto di arrivo ma un punto di partenza
e quindi perché questo amore grasse nel
tempo dovevamo nutrirlo e coltivarlo
andrea è una persona molto esterofila un
sognatore
io sono pazza un po pazzerella e poi
sono un po estroverso si vedono
e poi sono la sesta dico la sesta di sei
sorelle e quindi in quanto tale è molto
irrequieta per cui quando ci siamo
innamorati
abbiamo deciso che la nostra vita doveva
diventare il nostro progetto di vita
allora quando aspettavo carla per la più
grande e abbiamo deciso di prendere in
affitto una piccola casetta a parigi una
città romantica sexy e anche molto
stimolante per gli appassionati di arte
contemporanea come noi e li abbiamo
costruito il nostro nido d'amore procar
la doveva andare a scuola e ci siamo
interrogati rimaniamo a parigi o
torniamo in sicilia torniamo a favara
che il mio paese essere a parigi
significava a rincorrerci voli
permettendo per cui abbiamo deciso di
tornare a favara dove avremmo potuto
vivere insieme il nostro quotidiano
ti devo interrompere mamma io c'ero
perché non avete pensato a me
perché avete scelto per me perché avete
creduto al vostro progetto di vita senza
pensare che a parigi avrei potuto
avremmo potuto io e viola che comunque
sarebbe arrivata avere più possibilità
per le nostre vite
mi stavi togliendo del tempo che
dedicate delle case vecchie a parigi
stavamo sempre insieme mi portava i
parchi tornati in sicilia invece
dedicati quasi esclusivamente a 4
catapecchia
in realtà parlante in sicilia abbiamo
pensato a loro abbiamo pensato al nostro
futuro
perché io andrea ci siamo fatti una
promessa vivere a favara ma senza
lamentarci senza pensare che parigi
sarebbe stata più bella di favara senza
aspettare soprattutto che nessuno
cambiasse il nostro destino
vivere a casa nostra stare bene e darci
anche un ruolo all'interno di quella
società per cui nel centro storico di
favara ormai quasi totalmente
abbandonato abbiamo deciso di acquistare
delle piccole casette e iniziamo a
ristrutturarle e per molti quella
ristrutturazione sembrava rappresentare
anche quelli in quel caso un punto di
arrivo invece per noi rappresenta un
punto di partenza
l'inaf che il nostro progetto e sebbene
avessimo parlato con l'amministrazione
dell'epoca con gli abitanti di favara
con i nostri amici con le signore che
abitava nei sette cortili quel 25 giugno
del 2010 sempre come sia favara fossero
atterrati gli extraterrestri e lealtà la
gente non capiva che cosa stesse
succedendo e che cosa volevamo fare di
quei sette cortili forse volevamo
comandare la città ma invece no le case
inizialmente si colorarono di bianco
iniziarono a essere decorate da alcune
opere d'arte da fotografie e subito
quasi sembra che tutto fosse cambiata
addirittura queste lumache giganti
installate all'interno della della città
fino a giungere a quello che oggi sono
sette cortili dove noi stamo la nostra
bandiera lightness flag la bandiera
della senesità sì la bandiera della
felicità
la bandiera di chi vuole vivere in un
mondo migliore è fare di tutto perché
questo accada ma anche la bandiera di
chi vuole condividere perché sapete
molto spesso si pensa che la
condivisione sia un atto di sottrazione
perché se noi abbiamo una cosa e la
dividiamo in due
pensiamo di averne
metà ciascuno e invece no la
condivisione è un atto di
moltiplicazione e da quel giorno non ci
siamo mai più fermati abbiamo continuato
a rendere per gli spazi sempre più belli
abbiamo condiviso anche quegli spazi sì
perché in fondo a favore questo che è
successo noi abbiamo condiviso le nostre
idee le nostre risorse
le nostre conoscenze abbiamo iniziato ad
organizzare delle mostre mostre d'arte
abbiamo invitato sempre gente speciale
abbiamo organizzato dei workshop di
autocostruzione i nostri bambini hanno
avuto la possibilità di fare dei
laboratori di statue viventi e non ci
siamo mai più fermati sempre gente
straordinaria gente migliore di noi e
colora abbiamo anche iniziato dei
percorsi formativi come su la scuola di
architettura per bambini una scuola dove
vogliamo che i nostri bambini possano
pensare liberamente possano sviluppare
un senso critico possono essere abituati
alla magia della creatività ma possano
anche sperimentare perché mondo se noi
partiamo dal futuro se partiamo dai
nostri bambini
domani possiamo avere dei cittadini
migliori degli amministratori migliori e
probabilmente anche noi da anziani
diventeremo migliori solo condividendo
con loro e dandogli la possibilità anche
di iniziare a pensare che l'impossibile
possa diventare possibile
intanto a favara i turisti iniziamo ad
arrivare
e sapete tutte quelle persone che
all'inizio non capivano o comunque molte
di loro iniziarono a volerci bene
inizieranno a rendersi conto che a
favara le cose si potevano fare allora
iniziano a dante loro essere partecipi
di questo di questo processo a far parte
della nostra comunità iniziarono a fare
dei luoghi bellissimi più belli magari
dei nostri
pensate a favore a noi avevamo nel 2010
19 posti letto oggi ne abbiamo 250 posti
letto e la piazza che prima era un
maracanà
oggi è diventato un luogo che pullula di
pizzerie locali pub e palazzi nobiliari
che la circondano
sono stati quasi interamente
ristrutturata è come se il regno perduto
fosse stato ricostruito dalle sue stesse
fondamenta con cavalieri dall'armatura
scintillante aiutati dagli abitanti a
cui serviva soltanto una spinta per
ritornare combattivi e ridare l'uso il
regno sì sì c'è un po parliamo di re
artù di ginevra gli e reporter o dalla
pietra filosofale resistero tutti felici
e contenti
in fondo poi viviamo la nostra fiaba ma
è favara siamo felici perché a favara
poi vivere delle esperienze intense poi
incontrare gente straordinaria farne una
sorta di casbah siciliana entry e
trovino inaspettato in un centro storico
e poi se se ancora ti addentri ti può
capitare sbirciando di trovare un
agrumeto profumatissimo e poi trovi
d'oro ora sono le signore che abita nei
sette cortili vi assicuro che sono le
nostre migliori mediatrici culturali
sono la gerosa la zia maria lai antonia
loro ci interroga march chiedono e vi
racconto una volta la la zia maria che
noi abbiamo rinominato la regina dei
sette cortili arrivo questo artista
coreano dong martin un architetto
allora lui con aplomb
un ragazzo molto composto timido come
può essere una persona e asiatica molto
educata lei lo guardò e disse molto
dieta lo tirò se la bracciolo bacio come
se fosse il nipote arrivato dal da
lontano e per di più
lo invito a prendere il caffè a casa sua
ma il bello di di farm è che se capiti
un giorno qualsiasi
poi incontrare ragazzi al politecnico di
milano che magari lavorano alla
progettazione degli immobili ancora da
ristrutturare
oppure i ragazzi di di move che sono dei
ballerini che vengono a fare delle
residenze o vincenzo un ragazzo
siciliano che ha studiato prima negli
stati uniti o re d'inghilterra e poi è
tornato in sicilia perché vuole fare il
motivatore nella sua terra
oppure ancora i ragazzi bambini alla
scuola di architettura che progettano
degli orti urbani con per la città
perché farm in fondo è uno stato
dell'anima un modo di vivere e qualcuno
ha approvato a teorizzare questo effetto
farm perché io oggi sono qui a
raccontarvi di questa esperienza ma
probabilmente non riesco non riuscirò a
farlo bene qualcuno ha provato a
pareggiare questo effetto che è un
effetto rigenerante che crea fiducia e
senso di possibilità voglia di
cambiamento
senso di orgoglio di appartenenza perché
in realtà a favara sta succedendo
realmente qualcosa di importante c'è chi
dice che non avrebbe mai immaginato di
poter aprire un locale o iniziare
un'attività a favara e grazie a far ma
lo sta facendo e probabilmente questo
perché il nostro virus che forse un
virus buono sta iniziando a diffondersi
lo stiamo contagiando e i nostri giovani
oggi vivono in maniera diversa perché il
cambiamento apparentemente solo
economico non è perché un cambiamento
culturale un cambiamento sociale perché
oggi giovani si vestono come vogliono
vivono la propria sessualità in maniera
diversa e più libera e anche i loro
percorsi formativi sono trasversali
perché quando io ho scelto dovevo
scegliere quello che dovevo fare
per me c'erano cinque professioni io
potevo fare l'architetto giurisprudenza
te ti apre tutte le porte a me aperto
quella per fatto capire che non dovevo
fare giurista l'ingegnere e medico
invece oggi i nostri giovani pensano
anche in maniera trasversale perché in
fondo siamo cresciuti in una società in
cui
valiamo per il lavoro che facciamo è lo
stipendio che percepiamo e poi la
macchina le case a seconda di quante
case abbiano per come ci vestiamo e per
le amicizie che frequentiamo
poi torniamo a casa e ci rendiamo conto
che abbiamo vissuto la vita che gli
altri vorrebbero che noi vivessimo
abbiamo fatto le scelte che gli altri
vorrebbero che noi facessimo e lasciamo
a casa noi stessi
dimentichiamo di essere noi stessi e
questo effetto questo spirito invece che
quest'area che si respira dentro farm
dipende da infinite combinazioni
combinazioni di te e competenze e
conoscenze che al suo interno si
incontrano farlo c'è un posto
straordinario attraversato da architetti
artisti designer degente fantastica e
dove c'è una forza umana e creativa che
dimostra che fanno un posto speciale
la rende anche diversa da tutti gli
altri centri culturali perché oggi
favara e non solo farm e si scoprono
come un luogo internazionale
interessante attraversato da da turisti
la tanta gente speciale
essi sono tutti ai nostri amici e loro
dimostrano veramente che il vento su
favara è cambiato e nessuno nessuno mai
avrebbe pensato che la città poteva
cambiare in così poco tempo e
soprattutto che media ne potessero
parlare in maniera positiva perché in
fondo farm è un progetto impossibile
diventato possibile adesso capiamo
perché favare la città più bella del
mondo
sì perché favara e farlo ma soprattutto
è un progetto di una vita della nostra
vita e soprattutto se vi va di di essere
dei nostri
veniteci a trovare e ci aiuterete a
cambiare questo piccolo pezzo di mondo
gli astri usiamo a favara
[Applauso]